hey youtubers is Charlie the Milwaukee
did episode 7 video
totally great lead into what can be a
crazy finale
as little surprise where they left each
the group in terms of dramatic tension
most my focus is on Rick's group right
now but there's still some big step that
could happen
with the other two groups all the
characters got at least one really good
moment
and we promise our boat was the best
improvised Walker weapon
all season long real quick heads up new
enter the giveaway starts now it's just
a twenty dollar Amazon gift card all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video
super simple so covers boilers inclusion
within the apps to get starting with
top five moments number five Carl verses
Gabriel
you can also call this Gabriel verses
everyone left the church
Gabriel verses judit there's actually a
nice thought he says care to everything
he prolly is scared that little baby to
if you're a little confused obviously he
couldn't kill that Walker at the end
because he saw the cross
I'm guessing the plane knew that person
to that woman but it looks like he
turned around and went back to the
church
he's such a coward I wouldn't be
surprised if he didn't have the courage
to go out on his own
I haven't heard anything about Seth
Gilliam leaving the show are not coming
back for the second half to the season
so I don't know if he'll survive or
something big is going to happen
I don't think that they're gonna let the
finale go by without something crazy
going on
at the church is really that three
different groups at this point
yep BRICS group where the main action is
going to be then we have
karol me shown Judith Gabriel and then
we have abraham's group
which is now kinda like maggie's group
hands-down favorite moment was Carl
murder splaining how to push a machete
through someone's call sometimes the
night it's up to the other ones
out sale all the people he probably has
more sense than most
I mean probably pretty messed up little
kid I mean I see him snapping at some
point
like father like son but for now he
seems pretty solid
there was a brief moment but I was proud
Gabriel providing that Walker of
but then he went back to all Gabriel
when he couldn't killer
he just seems like the kinda person who
has suicide written all over his face
he's totally gonna burn in hell no
matter what so I don't be the committing
suicide would leave a mop any worse
it was kinda funny to see them ripping
down his church though it was like they
were ripping down his fate
art his sanity which I kids are kinda
the same thing
number four a bird
group picks up the pieces actually this
should be abraham's group becomes
maggie's group
or gone fishin there's the big WTF more
lies reveal last episode so
I can understand why they made this
story a little bit more hopeful
but I don't think they would allow
things to continue through the finale
without something crazy happening with
that group
and we saw that sanity and buckle up
it's the law I'm wondering what that
means
sometimes when I see things like that I
think they're referring to other parts
this story
like to talking about the officers are
they talking to the audience like
we need to buckle up because the story
is going to get freaking crazy
I think that there's a literal
interpretation to that I don't think
it's all metaphor
thinking about a little bit more to now
I'm actually wondering if they're just
gonna trying
crashed that fire truck through all
those walkers like that's why the need
to buckle up
it was really nice to get brassieres
backstory to if you look at the good
moral tale for telling people that you
think that they're important
it's funny that she said Abraham was the
first person to tell her
he needed her now that's kinda shit cunt
picked up the slack
she in Eugene will both be useful in
whatever new situation they find
themselves in
ter Horst Tony amazing his comedic
relief fist pump it
tattoo it on your face then bump it shit
the self-appointed morale officer now
I feel like she's actually come a long
way since season for Terra
I don't know this is completely forgiven
herself but I think all this trouble
with Eugene is taking her mind of bed
she seems pretty well-adjusted use its
people like Sasha
the people that are dealing with really
crazy stuff that you need to watch out
for
they're the ones that make terrible
decisions speaking of which Abraham
looks like he's slowly coming to but his
hand
do you see when he picked up water
bottle abuse it messed up and
they keep showing that he and I feel
like something crazy is gonna happen
with that at some point
we can just get the hand is like the red
herring right now are like the ginger
hearing against
number three bet saves Carol any time to
give weaker characters
big Hero Arts I get a little bit nervous
because it could be foreshadowing for
something really terrible happening
I haven't seen any overt spoilers about
characters dying
but all the theories Ron Carroll & bath
right now so
if you like everyone is watching their
scenes extra careful diseases any
potential clues
which is all over now because be found
at the teaser for the next episode
in that said there's nothing left in
terms of character development I feel
like better
has grown quite a bit at the hospital
she is strong arm itches strong before
he just proved it done
the whole scene with her work in the
grift totally hilarious it's like
oranges new black
Walking Dead addition she's like the
Taylor Schilling a walking dead now
do you feel like walking dead were
turned into orange is the new black just
a little bit dated stated the present
don't actually been a pretty funny show
to watch
I mean what he did is it meant to be a
funny show but you do get really
hilarious moments
number two Rick's group captures the
police officers
so the title the episode is crossed as
in
you have crossed the line that usually
tells you the villains are
like the people who go crazy right now
though that seems like reckons survivors
mostly just break though he disses
murder written all over his face
it is I love the way that they flip
things in this episode me the police
officers
seem like the boys a reason in Ric seem
like the crazy man
that's going to be really important for
the finale think they're really trying
to present both these groups
as fairly equal like brain situation
for trying to make the best of it was
trying to this the right way so we can
all walk away and sleep in our own beds
tonight
my favorite scenes from this whole
storyline garrels
improvise Walker weapon totally amazing
totally disgusting the same time
he basically grab it like a bowling ball
if you've ever seen Mystery Men Jean
gros below has bowling ball this
coincided
just reminded me that a little bit all
those walkers that they had
littered in that area they were calling
rodders but really they're all melting
and if you're confused as to why they
were so melted it was just the heat from
the Sun
that was my Maggie put the covering over
Eugene just so that he wouldn't get
super sunburnt
just think it is a PSA for using
sunblock even though we are nowhere near
beach season
such in Tyrese also totally touching
moment
I love the way they panned out though to
all the walkers in which Mike
really touching heard to super gross
touching her ged just like The Walking
Dead
you know dude is really tender moment in
pan over to someone running in the
street
just like get that makes you feel good
inside really good read here
and my number one WTF moment police
officer to leap was a fast one on Sasha
and get away
just to be clear before that she went
down I think there was a chance that
they're playing coulda worked
like the compromised now though they
still have two police officers
but the one police officer is gonna get
back inform the hospital what's going on
so they can prepare
like they can't prepare their defense is
be the taking away the owners surprised
that comes with Britt was depending on
really hoping is like rick's planned
purses everyone else's plan
because like I wanna go in and shoot
everyone and everyone else
his group as well as the police officers
their variable enemies
say no no we can totally do this another
way especially dare
even though he's super pissed about
losing Carol he's still the same
character the was not last episode
the one that Paul Carroll back from
doing the same type thing that rick is
getting ready to do
how our little darrell has become a man
carl's can on the same are two
it sank a South Park situation where the
adults are being crazy
in the young people are the same ones I
will say I'm happy Sasha didn't get
pushed out that window
I thought the doubters was gonna happen
whenever he walked up behind her and he
was totally gonna pull a fast one
aged in oak if he's gonna knock her out
are pusher right off the ledge
they're definitely few characters I
don't think are gonna die in the finale
the weird thing about predicting Walking
Dead s is that it seem like
over the last five years the show wants
to keep as many people as possible
like the more people who keeps the more
stories you can tell P easier it is to
prolong the show
speed s I feel like betting Carol are
still the top in the hit list
Emily can he's been posting so much of
her music stuff but it makes me feel
weird like
yeah they're getting ready to go on
winter break so all the actors and had
extra time did you
whatever they do whenever the night
doing walking dead but you always wonder
you like
mmm maybe she's preparing for another
career breaking the two though I still
feel like Carol
is higher on the hit list beth is
agreement to go up you like the best
chances on Carol just because
she's so incapacitated right now it's
allergies gonna wake up and just go
apeshit on everyone
knowing Carol that may not stop her from
trying which I should be pretty
interesting to watch
she's gonna take anyone out I would love
to see her take out that crazy doctor
maybe some is durables to maybe take him
out with the gerbil
now be great that issue that using a
gerbil as an improvised weapon
has issued a good jumping-off point so
always repairman from the episode
and let me know here's my big question
for you what's the next improvised
weapon you wanna see on the show
personally I believe just wanna see a
durable used as a weapon
like you had better someone just shut
one down someone's throat
overall I give the apps that I saw a
B-plus I totally love the attention that
they're building
in atlanta but I felt like began to drop
the ball
on the other areas it said there's no
way the abraham's group driving that
fire truck
through a bunch walkers is going to be
as crazy as what's gonna go down at the
hospital
and who knows what's going to happen
back at the church if you look upon
things they could do with
corals group to match the tensioner the
energy
up the other group would be to have
Gabriel just totally smashed someone up
Michael Walker
or some intruder there's been no signs
that that's going to happen
either gabriel's going to have some sort
of your a moment or Carls is going
straight up kill 'em
really his only purpose on the show
right now has been as a improvised
innkeeper
for the survivors in there already
tearing down the in karl said it himself
you can stay in one place for too long
anymore mean
did they're not going to be there in the
second half of the season cedar Gables
gonna have to man up
in go with them or he's gonna have to
die irregardless
he cannot stay at that church and to
leave and said Gilliam
as an actor but I feel like his
character just has not been serviced
really well the season so far he is a
big character in the comics
it's totally possible to get taken that
route usually when new actors are signed
to The Walking Dead
they have options in their contract in
case the producers want to use them
later
it when people are brought on as guest
stars in season five sometimes they have
options the cum regulars
in season six and so on and so on I will
say for all the people that are watching
for behind-the-scenes pics they're still
filming episodes he can actually like
see the actors walking around on sets
and doing stuff
there are some things that lead me to
believe you know certain characters that
we think might die
are not gonna die are just caution you
if you're looking at those
the characters could be onset for
flashback scenes
just because they're on said doesn't
mean their character still alive on all
great episode great lead into the finale
lot questions raised
especially the buckle your seatbelt
thing but again I think there's gonna
drive that part right
right through that her to Walker's they
made it sound like it's going to be some
sort a slip n slide
some sort of gooey disgusting slip and
slide
I will try and do some extra videos are
definitely be doing some bonus videos
when it's off the air when it's on break
ill come back pretty quickly though
but feel free to leave me any request
for special bonus videos the really
wanna see
and be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will continue to give away
in the offseason don't worry just every
time a post about his buddy are just
doing around the giveaway
just like normal cuny tomorrow
indication to me talk about it add new
mobile links appears to be on your
mobile phone a tablet it's the same
links that I add over here
so nice and simple right now click here
for the CUNY allow that
tomorrow in click here for last week's
episode thank you so much watching
lot of hype I I'll see you guys tomorrow